Hey youtubers it's Charlie, I'm back from
Vidcon. This will be my review of episode
3 of Korra. There was so much going on Friday
I decided to separate it out in the name of
sanity. I'll just say this, if you ever have
to edit on a laptop. Don't forget your mouse,
it won't go well.
Hello to all the new people, if you're just
finding me I'm doing weekly Korra videos.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything. I'll
be doing bonus videos, episode reviews and
Q&As. Next week is weird because there's no
new episode. Two more weeks before Episode
4 airs on July 11th.
Also, the giveaway is also good for this video
too. All you have to do to participate is
be a subscriber and leave a comment on this
video. I'll be picking one random person from
the comments and announcing who it is next
week.
So this will be just like my episode 1 and
2 review except I'm just doing TOP 5 moments
and then my review. This is all mostly going
to revolve around The Earth Queen, the Dai
Lee and the shady business in Ba Sing Se.
Careful for spoilers from the episode if you
haven't seen it yet.
Everybody ready? Okay, here we go, Number
5 - Mako and Bolin are too good for rotten
fruit
When you look at all the different storylines
in the episode, I feel like Mako and Bolin
reconnecting with their family was every bit
as important as Korra getting the Earth Queen's
help. And on top of it all, Mike and Bryan
tied them getting stuck in the Lower Ring
to the Dai Li. In case you blinked you may
have missed them standing there looking for
more new airbenders.
It's pretty easy to understand how they could
have gotten disconnected from their extended
family. Technically they had never met them.
Their father was the Earthbender, Saan. He
left to make his way in the world and fell
in love with a Firebender, their mother. So
they weren't born in Ba Sing Se and since
their parents died when they were little kids,
they never new their cousins existed.
Whenever Bolin was convincing Mako to drift
his way back to the group he said they were
going to visit Grandma, so at some point they
would have had to learn about each other.
I may have missed it, but I think it was because
Bolin's Nuktuk Movers were being screened
in Ba Sing Se and his Grandmother knew who
they were.
But however they did connect, I'm interested
to see if their cousin, the Rotten Fruit vendor,
ends up helping them free the airbenders.
The Dai Li plot and the Earth Queen secret
army was kind of teased during the dinner,
but right now, there isn't really a reason
for their family to fight with them. And their
Grandmother even got really weird when they
spoke ill of the Queen. Like she was a little
brainwashed, which reminds me of the Dai Li
in last airbender.
In case you didn't notice, their Grandmother
was the same girl that had a crush on Zuko
during the Ba Sing Se episodes of Last Airbender.
Number 4 - Korra and Asami Learn about the
plight of the people
While they were out tax collecting during
the battle, mr hockey mask calls it out. The
Queen is wrongfully taxing her citizens. At
some point this season, that will have to
be dealt with, but I'm not expecting it to
happen anytime soon. They introduced too many
new plot threads to resolve anything completely
in the next episode.
Korra is probably just going to keep poking
at the Earth Queen until she gets her to snap
and unleash the Dai Li on her. They did already
take Kai, but that was incidental. They didn't
know he was connected with the Avatar when
they targeted him.
The taxation is just the surface level problem,
I'm assuming she's using all that money to
support the huge army she's trying to build
in secret. So Korra is going to have to solve
all the Earth Kingdom problems by first dealing
with the Airbender kidnapping crisis.
Number 3 - The new Earth Queen is a real Bitch
Big 180 from her father the Earth King from
Last Airbender. She seems like an Azula-type
person who just doesn't have bending. So I
can totally imagine her dominating her father
while she was growing up, just doing whatever
she wanted.
She's totally nutters, but I'm wondering if
she'll have an "Azula Goes Crazy" moment.
Where she just absolutely snaps.
In her defence, when she was explaining some
of her gripes to Korra. Zuko and Aang technically
did take her land to build Republic City.
But this is what happened. The used land that
the Fire Nation had taken from the Earth Kingdom
to build colonies during the war of invasion.
So it's only natural that Zuko would use that
Land to make a city dedicated to peace. But
it's like stealing 5 dollars from your neighbor,
then donating the 5 dollars to charity. Yes
you did something good, but you achieved it
with stolen merch. So the Earth Queen's argument
is valid.
I could totally see her marching an airbending
army on Republic City trying to take it back
in the name of the Earth Kingdom. Imagine
the spirits living there now going to war
with them. It would be like the Avatar Wan
episodes all over again.
It's unclear why she felt the need to build
the airbender army in the first place, but
it's possible the Dai Li are manipulating
her just like her father and it's just not
as obvious because she seems so self assured
and stubborn.
Number 2 - Korasami Ass Kicking
I got such a good vibe from their fight. I
wonder what the dynamic would have been had
Korra been the first person to bump into Asami
instead of Mako and they never did all the
romance stuff in books 1 and 2.
I love the implied 'ships, just because it's
funny as subtext, but I can totally do without
full on teen romance. I get the general sense
that all of you guys are pretty pumped for
Korasami this year. With Naga they're like
a whole Scooby Doo team all by themselves.
In that situation Korra would definitely be
like a cross between Shaggy and Fred and Asami
would be like a cross between Velma and Daphne.
It's like they have all the good qualities,
the brains and the courage, but at the same
time they're super awkward. Which is totally
going to make Book 3 so much more fun.
If any of you are graphic artists and want
to send me some fanart of Korra Asami and
Naga as the Scooby Doo gang I'll be sure to
add it in my bonus video next Friday.
and my Number 1 moment - The Dai Li is building
a Secret Airbending Army
So many questions here, we can only assume
that since the Earth King disbanded the Dai
Li during Last Airbender, they somehow resurfaced
and ingratiated themselves with the Earth
Queen. It's possible that they rebuilt themselves
under the guise of 'new leadership' and have
just been running another long con involving
her or taking advantage of her.
I know in Last Airbender they were using the
King as a puppet, but it's totally possible
the Earth Queen is complicit in their shady
business. It all depends on what the motivation
is for building the army. And I think it has
something to do with what Zaheer was saying
when he escaped.
About closing your mind to the possibility
of a new reality. The Queen probably wants
to either take back her land or just use the
army to keep the raiding parties from stealing
back the gold she's taking. That seems more
and more like a Robin Hood plot point, the
raiders.
Whenever they met Kai, we got the whole "Looks
can be deceiving" speech, so I won't be surprised
if all the raiders are really just freedom
fighters trying to help the people.
But now it's your turn, let me know what your
favorite moment was. I mistakenly talked about
the bending twins and zuko during my last
video, I just forgot they were part of this
third episode, that's why I left them out
of this. Otherwise they would have been like
my second favorite moment.
So big news, next week there is no new episode,
Jul 11th is when episode 4 will air. I'll
still be doing a bonus video Friday the 4th
though. Be sure to subscribe to get it. And
nick will probably re-air the first three
episodes.
I will be at Anime Expo in los angeles, so
if you want to find me and say hi just make
sure to follow me on twitter, facebook or
instagram. I'm usually pretty good about doing
updates on where I'm at.
Right now click here for my episode 1 and
2 video and click here to learn about the
top 5 characters I'm most excited about in
Book 3.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!